charlebois ça je vous avais dit quelque
part je n'ai aucune lassitude pour la
chanson quand j'étais enfant je
connaissais déjà 200
je ne sais pas si j'ai dit 200 me suis
toujours intéressé à la chanson c'était
une affaire de famille la chanson ce
n'était pas leur métier bien sûr mais
tout le monde chantait tout le monde
aimait beaucoup la chanson mon père ma
mère
ma soeur longtemps coeur ma grand mère
tout le monde alors forcément dû
composer leur nom de l'enfant serait été
familiarisés avec toutes les chansons
qui se chantait à cette époque là celle
qui se chante et à toutes les époques
poussière et trois ou quatre générations
juillet de la guitare non pas du tout le
canadien je tapais sur la table c'est
comme ça ma compagne on peut parler de
ça
quand vous avez appris la musique aux
jeux pas tellement après la musique j'ai
un peu appris la musique à 7 et puis
j'ai abandonné laissé tomber
m'astreindre à faire des gammes tout ça
ça me plaisait pas beaucoup
je voulais tout de suite ou d'un
instrument ce qui fait je ne suis jamais
arrivé à jouer d'aucun instrument
légalement ils vénèrent devrait
maintenant
après je pris la guitare et puis comme
c'est jacques grello qui m'a conseillé
de chanter en scène avec une guitare
j'en avais gens jouer un petit peu déjà
ma faim j'ai pendant cinq six mois j'ai
travaillé nuit et jour pour arriver à
faire quelques les quelques accords dont
j'avais besoin pour mes premières
chansons que vous êtes à paris vous
aviez déjà des chansons en poche
maintien oui je suis venu même avec
plein de chansons en poche mais je
venais pour les faire chanter par
d'autres d'ailleurs je n'ai pas changé
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où patachou m'a
pris mes premières chansons phares et
première que le public ait connu les
bancs publics la prière le brave margot
la chasse aux papillons et comme j'avais
d'autres chansons du avait chanté tout
ce que j'avais à ce moment là j'en avais
une trentaine mais trois premiers
disques ans a et g elle a pensé qu'elle
ne pouvait pas chanter le gorille
sujet repenti histoires des gens d'heure
alors m'a demandé de chanter après le
spectacle chez elle dans son cabaret
elle se tenait à côté de moi et me
disait jean lesage en deçà et je
chantais il est au public sais c'est pas
un chanteur de métier si ça vous plaît
ça vous plaît si ça ne vous plaît pas le
spectacle terminé et c est ça a marché
tout de suite c'est je dois je dois dire
que sans pâte à choux vraisemblement
serait pas tout à fait là d'un temps
après mondy et n'ai aucune lassitude de
la chanson et de ces périodes justement
comme celle de maintenant qu'il précède
par exemple un passage à bobino non
comme une depuis l'âge de 5 ans j'aime
la chanson je continue à l'aimer n'y a
pas de raison ça ça va t'il petit avoir
je peux ne plus avoir les faire je peux
écrire des chansons des chansons que le
public n'aime pas mais m'en lasse et moi
même je ne crois pas remarqué que quand
j'écris une chanson qu'elle ne plaît pas
je la jette dans jeté beaucoup comme ça
pas mal
d'années bien j'étais
presque la moitié de ce que j'ai écrit
les nouvelles chansons de cette année
disons qu'une inspiration qu'on retrouve
déjà quelque part dans les deux ans que
vous aviez dit il et fou de perdre sa
vie pour une idée maintenant vous allez
de chanson qui s'appelle mourir pour une
idée la soixantaine qui le dit c'est la
suite de l'autre vous savez les thèmes
viennent chez moi parce que d'abord il
ya pas 36 militaires les termes sont peu
nombreux y'a que les gens qui n'ont pas
d'idées qui s'imaginent que
les idées les thèmes sont nombreux
c'est parce qu'il ya pas trente six
mille thème est plus que je pensais un
beau jour en sus une idée me vient une
image me vient de verre me viennent
viennent du ciel ou des jeunes c'est
celle où et quand j'en fais une chanson
semble sans me poser de questions je ne
me regarde pas écrire
j'écris ce qui me passe par la tête et
puis quand c'est fini
le critique que j'ai en moi des 6 2 6
ça peut être livré au public ou non
un des thèmes parce qu'il y en a quand
même qui sont revenus fréquemment chez
vous ce celui de la mort de lady aussi
ailleurs je m'en fiche de la mort mais
cette des autres me dérange bougrement
oui
tragédie sa verve j'étais j'avais sans
doute perdu quelqu'un peu de temps avant
bien sûr on a cru que parce que j'aime
mener j'avais conduit la mort sur le sur
une scène de music hall j'étais
préoccupé par l'idée de ma propre mort
bien sûr j'en suis préoccupé mais comme
tout le monde bien sûr il est toujours
triste de penser qu' on ne va plus voir
on n'a plus rien sentir n'a pu rien
n'est prouvé m'enfin c'est pas chez moi
plus plus sensible que chez d'autres ça
le serait même moins puisque je joue
avec je ne crois pas que ce soit une
hantise c'est une hantise mais juste
normal juste ce qu'il faut seulement
comme j'écris quand une idée revient sur
la mort bien sûr les crises besoin de
chansons j'ai besoin de renouveler mon
répertoire
quand j'ai une chanson sur ma mort je
l'écris pyjama s'est présentée avec la
mort ça aussi c'était une histoire une
affaire de famille mon père ma mère mon
grand père on aimait bien rigoler avec
les enterrements vous prenez plaisir à
la narguer un peu bêtement
je ne sais pas si c'est ça non je crois
que c'est parce que parce que ça me
réussit assez de parler de la mort en
général j'en parle pourrir
gens parlent pour m'amuser sauf dans une
ou deux il finira il entend c'est une
blague la supplique pour être enterré à
7 finalement c'est presque de la
publicité pour inciter les gens à venir
se tromper dans la méditerranée dans les
rares bons du bonheur vous parlez de
petites joies ou de vendre joueurs mais
pas du bonheur ou le sol bonheur là où
vous savez sauraient pas parler c'est
pas trop ce que c'est je sais que je
pense qu'on peut avoir des joies comme
ça mais le bonheur lui même je ne vois
pas ce que c'est je ne sais pas du tout
ce que ça peut être il est difficile
dans ce monde dans le monde actuel
surtout
être pleinement heureux me semble moi je
n'y parviens pas ce que vous êtes
heureux en scène
oui maintenant je suis heureux lance
c'était à mes débuts j'avais eu du mal
et on a cru bien sûr que c'était le mât
par un mépris envers le public se tue
qui était fausse que je prends la peine
d'écrire les chansons le plus
correctement que je peux c'est la preuve
que je ne méprise pas le public mais
comme je n'étais plus préparés à cet âge
là j'ai débuté à 30 ans à passer en
public ça m'a un peu gêné au début de
devenir en scène et venir aux gens et
écouter ce que j'ai fait c'est toujours
un peu gênant quand même de s'imaginer
que ce coup-ci ce qu'est ce qui se passe
dans notre petite tête peut intéresser
un grand nombre de gens alors ça ça me
gênait un peu plus petit à petit le
public est en venu vers moi j'ai avec
sympathie je me suis pris un peu au jeu
dire que je ne pourrais pas me passer en
signe de monter en scène ça serait
serait faux mais ça me manquerait quand
même ce rendez vous que j'ai tous les
deux ans dont 3 ans avec le public me
fait du bien
et le fait que une certaine époque bien
vous avez pris conscience que ce que
vous apportiez au public et était
peut-être quelque chose d'important que
ça a changé quelque chose dans votre vie
à vous dans votre façon de raisonner
disant ça je ne sais pas le plus je ne
sais pas on verrait mieux salle
l'extérieur en admettant que l'idée
maintes à quelqu'un d'étudier la morale
de mes chansons ça on pourrait mieux le
voir que moi moi je ne vois pas vous
prenez j'écris quand même au fil de la
plume au fil des idées qui me viennent
les jeunes et vos chansons et étudiants
m s'est passé est anormal supérieur par
exemple il a surpris or rien ne me
surprend vous savez c'est pas facile à
surprendre
mon frère me fait quand même plaisir
vous savez du moment qu'on s'intéresse à
mes chansons j'écris les chansons pour
mon plaisir pour le plaisir de mes amis
et pour le public de ceux qui veulent
bien les écouter les aimait alors je
suis toujours satisfait quand on aime
mes chansons quand on m'assassine dans
la presse quand quelqu'un m'arrêtent
dans la rue parce que ça m'est arrivé
pour me dire vos chansons sont mauvais
ça me plait pas tout ça ça ne me ça ne
me rends pas malade mais j'aime quand
même mieux de concret disent qu'on les
aime mais ça ne me rends pas malade non
plus quand je sais bien que tout le
monde n'aime pas mes chansons et je
n'écris pas pour tout le monde j'écris
pour ceux qui aiment tient à garder
plusieurs de vos biographie elle
commence presque toutes parts dominant
toute la chanson temps des chalets mios
gras l'oeuvre de georges brassens
suspension ou non la saint-jean
excessive au passage je ne sais pas si
ça me paraît excessif moi je crie les
chansons voyez alors les autres les
reçoivent comme ils veulent y en a qui
là qu'il m'a dit qu'il vient de me dire
quand j'écoute vos chansons je suis plus
heureux de ça ça me fait plaisir
l'oeuvre de brassens est une autre
histoire mais ne mentionne pas décrire
une oeuvre j'écris je vous dis ce que ce
que j'ai envie d'écrire je décris avec
joie même quand je parle de la mort et
je suis content qu'on le reçoit avec
joie ça ne va pas plus loin présent je
ne tiens pas qu'on fasse des thèses
qu'on en fasse ça ne me fait pas de
peine ou enfin il ne faut pas prendre ça
trop au sérieux quand même c'est une
histoire de chansons il faut que ça
finisse par des chansons ça aussi
ayant tu avec lui
toujours fait bon ménage
je sais mais célébré sans être
inconvenant
tant de corps féminins
ton plus vers la pana
que tout ce qu'ils ont vu
dix élus cible en
sus tt mon ultime chant
mon chant du cygne 1
mon dernier billet tout
mon message
d'adieu
or malheureusement
léman qui le désigne
le dispute à l'excès râble
alors league
c'est là ma le peste soit
renault cette homonymie lieu
c'est pas juste madame
et c'est désobligeant
que ce morceau le roi
deux fautes au milieu
porte le même nom
qu'une foule de la bulle
fasse le ciel qu'un jour
dans un tas de l'énigme
un poète inspiré
que pelé gardien
[Musique]
effaçant d'un coup
des siècles
dafani
passe est vrai
khelil non chrétiens
en attendant
madame
il est le semblerait dôme argent
mais fausse adorateurs
en serait tout bénef
n'allez
merdre levure
que pour lui rendre hommage
il
aux moyens
plus où et que je les connais
mais plus je les reconnais
[Musique]